uh here's a crazy one shireen if you
thought
that
the broncos having no quarterbacks
available by the way they're all now
officially back except for jeff driscoll
who tested positive the three who were
knocked out on saturday and placed on
covid reserve because of close proximity
to jeff driscoll from that meeting that
happened last week those three are back
brett rippon drew lock and blake bortles
that was strange in and of itself
and and look i've i've taken great pains
to not disclose the name of the coach i
know who the coach is but one of the
assistant coaches and i didn't
understand this and i had this thing
in my pocket for two days before i
finally wrote it because i wanted to
make sure i understood exactly what
happened i gave everyone involved the
team the league and the uh
and the testing company bioreference
laboratories an opportunity to to
respond
um
when you do a point of care test there's
apparently a machine involved
and the machine gets calibrated and the
machine gets calibrated with some sort
of compound that registers a positive so
you know the machine is properly working
or properly calibrated to
determine
whether or not someone is positive well
they use some synthetic compound not
live virus to calibrate the machine to
make sure the machine is ready to
properly show positives
and one thing led to another yadda yadda
a swab with that synthetic compound that
is used to calibrate the machine ended
up the nose of a broncos assistant coach
now
i
and you know someone along the way told
me well you know we've done 700 000 of
these tests this year it's like yeah but
this is the kind of mistake that should
never happen even even if you do 700
million of them
um
and and there was concern now there's no
chance he could have been infected you
know
bioreference laboratories decline
comment they say they never talk about
these kinds of situations but they knew
what i was going to report and uh they
didn't push back on what i told them i
was going to report they just declined
comment it's just odd it's just strange
and it shows you weird things can happen
when you're dealing with this
this element on top of everything else
you deal with as a football team and i
guess it's just something to be aware of
and and maybe if you're being tested
especially point of care keep your eyes
open and don't be afraid to ask
questions if if it looks like
something's unfolding maybe the way that
it shouldn't unfold especially if you're
being tested on a regular basis and you
become aware of the procedure keep your
eyes open and have your mouth ready to
move if you say hey wait a minute i'm
not sure that that thing should go up my
nose and and here's the other wrinkle
since i've reported that shireen i've
heard from another
coach who
possibly had something similar happen
we've yet to nail that down to the point
where we can report it but uh
it may not have been the only time it
happened this season
you know mike of all the crazy stories
we've had this year incredible stuff
that we never expected to be talking
about writing about whatever
about
this to me ranks as the most
unfathomable thing that has happened all
year and i am sure that coach was scared
to death that he had been infected
by the virus not of his own doing and
can you imagine what would have happened
mike if he had gotten the virus based on
that swab going up his nose as you said
whether they do 700 000 to this point or
700 million this is something that
should absolutely never happen and the
fact that it happened once is incredible
if it happened more than once it's
unbelievable uh and and there need to
needs to be an investigation of why this
is happening and continue to happen if
that's the case
yeah and again the
folks involved will say there was no
chance he was infected but it was enough
that he did test positive on the point
of care test he was out for a day
didn't get infected but when the
president of the testing company calls
you up to personally apologize something
happened that shouldn't have happened
something happened to mobilize the ceo
of this company that otherwise would
seem to be you know a fairly busy person
to make that phone call and try to put
the person's mind at ease but the
concern was still there so uh just a
strange situation and
again if if you're only being tested
once you don't know what to look for but
if you're being tested on a regular
basis keep your eyes open any coaches
any players out there because there's
the chance something could happen that
shouldn't happen
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports